when Bali I would never have guessed you
would know there's something you're
worried about
[Music]
somebody what I would find boys 500
stars they gave from Arizona came got a
prescription all of our [__] shot he
popped my on what are you mad yeah oh
yeah
wow they bought them out of stars
that's unbelievable what did he do me
right to the peel bar
well that [__] [__] cloud what type
of [__] is this uncle Joey here with my
main man Lisa at Wednesday night the
19th enough with the debate they're both
[__] lying to you who gives a [__]
you still gotta get up and swing dick
with three [__] hands tomorrow morning
the Dodgers are losing five nothing
that's always interesting somebody's
getting stabbed outside that [__]
game tonight three white guys that are
in town oh my god
we shouldn't we had a great [__]
veggie stew burger right in the [__]
head much a beautiful night here as
usual bong hits edibles explosives
[__] Lee humming making funny noises
[__] all night it's gonna be one of
those nights tonight cuz we're going
deep in the catacombs of debt you
understand me and the best part you're
here [__] is young eighteen get
the [__] off the periscope right now
[Music]
there we go we're getting better at lung
power I got a warm this [__] mule up
you don't say
get it together Nelly uncle Joey's here
put that [__] air on it's hot man
[Music]
we got edible after edible after edible
tonight it's a non-stop showcase a
better bowels tonight you're saying
that's how we do it we wouldn't do it
any other [__] way we're going for
these tonight these things will kill you
right off the bat these little [__]
things tremendous well I do like [__]
18 of them 200 milligrams apiece there's
one Foley look at this looks like dead
[__] bodies I let me show you
[__] yeah I'm gonna give you a
green apple
oh yeah we're gonna deep to the
catacombs of one of these look at the
empty boxes everywhere don't give a [__]
it's Wednesday night oh yeah this thing
is harder than hard these like expired
Vikings they still got kicked on me on
sale oh yeah we're going deep into the
hemispheres of debt to that
I'm liking at least I have you sees
little [__] did you see him at
your store get them and make sure their
heart you don't want them fresh do you
want that you can hit a [__] kid in
the head you're [__] in this hello
fracture and
[Music]
in this corner TKO in this quantity kayo
who's gonna win not you [__] ah
it's a beautiful night to see you guys I
missed you
I'm back I'm rested and I'm ready to
sling some [__] dick okay the last
[__] three months I've been involved
in this [__] move and writing and
doing this this week is Runkle joy
I just been making some notes a little
bit of this a little of that and no I
didn't watch the debate here we go bomb
number [__] - I'm not even gonna chew
this one I'm just saying hell at home
and let the Sharks in my stomach [__]
bury this thing I'm listening to a
tremendous album Oh
[Music]
so loving you with the Allman Brothers
sometimes he feels Kaka
[Music]
human brothers the Fillmore East people
these guys here this is the real deal no
tattoos no [__] hats no nothing they
just came the [__] party and tension
up look at Lee over there struggling we
forgotten we're doing these two we're
going deep time enough is enough people
enough was enough
I don't care what you need to do I don't
care you need to go see Blanco on the
corner and get some [__] pay I don't
we're going to eat you understand me I
don't give leave to take a sleeping pill
with three amaretto vodka I don't give a
[__] jack
look at this monster BAM green apple
delicious nutritious and you see the
devil guaranteed or your money back
look at this looks like a battlefield
[Music]
but not this [__] nice shirt there oh
[__]
it is what it is it is what it is now
we're going deep with these these are
the cherry on the sundae somebody's
never a nervous breakdown but I've been
having nervous breakdowns all my life I
don't give a [__] one more I'm gonna do
me that's okay another great done I'll
leave your perfect either ride a
breakdown twenty some people go to jail
and family enough with the chitty-chat
load up that [__] barn Uncle Joe is
coming to town [__] whether it's
Vegas
Boston [__] woods Irvine Portland
Oregon I'm coming to town load up that
[__] bomb [__] forget the
debate thing that's nothing to you you
still have to get up tomorrow you still
gotta [__] do a thousand things ain't
nobody there with no [__] then below
ain't nobody there with instructions
what do you give a [__] you've been
living off your own [__] instructions
look PhD tasking your salary [__] the
dentist he can suck my dick and call me
shorty here we go well that's it that's
that people there's no flag practice
here
there's no celebrities here there's
nobody talking on the phone trying to
impress you
it's just a Jew and a [__] Cuban tell
they talk some [__] out we got the
podcast late o'clock we'll do a few
bonnets if you don't mind if you don't
mind I'm saying you think I would give a
[__] if you did if you don't like
bonnets go shoot yourself in the Stanley
this is Lee's world is Uncle Joe's world
[__] and this is the Allman Brothers
world into this [__] going on behind me
right now man what's going on behind me
right now real [__]
[Music]
you know it takes a lot more than buying
a shirt and going to his old man concert
make them believe you know what's
crackin
we know what's crackin hey I don't know
about the moon I know about politics
talk about religion we put music I said
he will you banging out four [__]
hours you understand what's up date BJ
come on
[Music]
tremendous people we live in the country
have the opportunity of dubonnet's and
Jerry's kids where the [__] do you live
[__] get up do a Bunga it's
Wednesday night have some dignity
save yourself before the devil [__]
comes into your life
and takes your [__] soul by going to
Starbucks and hanging out with other
[__] jerk balls huh let's seem so
interesting with your [__] glasses
throw those glasses away you don't need
them you got twenty nineteen vision who
little [__] you [__] with go eat a
carrot you don't need no glasses to be
cool you don't need nothing to be cool
ballsack a [__] heart and nothing but
batteries [__] Mike uncle Joey
bondage for Jerry's kids
[Music]
who's better than you have you thought
about that today who's better than you
you're there sitting on your [__]
couch on your phone thinking about how
bad you got the fat lady with the
[__] Virginia ham on the one
complains you ain't got no bread let's
do another bunk we think it's time for
me to go you still got some energy left
don't go nowhere we still got two more
hundred to drop is it burning these are
three t-shirts for ten bucks will write
your [__] at the fat man store double X
young saintly you're putting that button
oh there you go that's a good bunkie
right there that's got all the nutrients
count lemon juice there you go
it's open it's Wednesday October 19th
that's all we're living for you don't
say Passover is a month away I don't
give a [__] I don't give a [__] about
Friday come on I give a [__] about
tonight [__] but let's do this Mazel Tov
let's go con sucks after you do this you
could sit on the bump and break it let's
go pijo
[Music]
there you go Lee that's the one that
killed [__] Lincoln that's for one
that's the one baby boy oh [__] you're
back [__] your thumb up until we
lost you thing we have two different
week coming that that's [__] it now
brain freeze I got some flawless this
does [__] that chick from the
progressive shades off a [__] toast
yeah this is some real weed over here I
don't know what the [__] you live or
what you're doing with your life but I'm
telling you right now you should live
down the block it will be smoking some
big reef every [__] day hearing
cattle do much I'm gonna lightly I am
running things I'm a [__] bum but I'm
a bum that has at the time you know Sam
[Music]
the one thing you have not hung this
bong keep clogging up take this home
soaked in alcohol I'm gonna get along
clean we make that hole big it's gonna
be like a hole above who's been in
business for 30 years this is the whole
of the [__] of 18 year old is just
starting the world of dick the world of
dick is a [__] up world some people
want to play look at this [__] these
[__] three basketball players with
this chick she said that [__] they
muscle into a house is [__] you know the
world of dick is terrible stay out of
the world of dick stay out of the world
of dick [__]
[Music]
it's a beautiful thing do you want fire
yeah
you on fire I'm CUBAN on fire Cuban on
fire
tonight's that we have this little time
to spend together you know I'm a [__]
idiot
that's amazing even better I'm not
trying to do nothing to prove to be
somebody me and Lea just two regular fat
books just try to have a good time and
do a podcast that's it there's not BMWs
there's no quadrats there's no [__]
fast cars it's just two regular [__]
- it's just like you burn your lips you
don't be in the reef of business
eventually gonna break your [__]
something a finger an eyeball I burned
this on 82 don't [__] use it a bomb
exploded you I'm saying what was left
that's how good the weed was the bong
[__] exploded one day is the Allman
Brothers coming at your [__]
[Music]
we ready to do this last 200 are you are
you ready to see El Diablo [__]
you're not ready to see El Diablo you
don't want to run with uncle Joey and
his [__] goombah of death Lisa at
that's his no-name the Goomba of death
understand me I hope you people having a
good time
there's nothing listen like I said
there's nothing going on in it's just a
couple [__] dudes doing bondage with
you together like a family
how lucky a wiener we have to do this at
night
[Music]
that's it and that's that whoo yeah the
height is pumping [__] will be
back in about ten minutes
what is it youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz we're back in ten minutes
love you [__] without you I have
nothing
thank you for [__] joining us thank
you for being father podcast and don't
believe what you hear on that [__]
television is second and that's it go
smoke some more refund I'll see you
[__] in about 10-15 minutes
ever sometimes I feel oh [__]
oh [__] here we go constant